bonjour bienvenue dans cette leçon jean
baptiste monge stéphane hains alors
c'est une leçon aujourd'hui spécial
legrand karpov puisqu'on va voir la
défense karo kann une défense usité par
carpeaux et aussi petrossian le grand
champion du monde alors c'est une
défense qui a été très utilisé par les
joueurs dits positionnelle c'est à dire
une histoire qui cherchait plutôt à voir
une position très solide sans grande
faiblesse forçant faiblesse de pièces
sans faiblesse de pions donc
effectivement karpov n'a pas été long à
le prendre dans son répertoire tout au
long de sa carrière
même maintenant il le joue la voir ses
jeunes années il est championne du monde
il a joué tout le temps donc c'est une
ouverture maintenant qui est très connu
sur le plan de la théorie puisque
beaucoup de joueurs ont aussi repris à
leur compte cette défense par exemple de
relief qui est un très bon grand maître
russe qui la joue très souvent bas
relief aussi beriev aussi alors on dit
souvent que c'est une arme anti
attaquant c'est une arme deux défenseurs
donc c'est souvent on dit que les blancs
se casse les dents sur la carreau cannes
donc on va voir ça aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que pour les gens aux attaques
contre joué aux quatre avec les blancs
eh bien henri surprise oui ça m'est pas
un joueur franchement parce que
c'est une ouverture qui est très solide
et il faut être patient et quand on est
venu avec des intentions peut-être mais
dit que zac et de sauter à la gorge de
l'adversaire et bien le carreau cannes
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle parce que
ça veut dire que ça va prendre plus de
temps que prévu
alors on va voir ça tout de suite à
cette karo kann aujourd'hui donc spécial
variante qu'avaient les 17
on va voir pourquoi parce qu'il ya
plusieurs variantes avec la rocade
évidemment e46 alors caractérise déjà
tout de suite là car au cannet voilà
c'est le coup voilà avec l'idée que le
noir veulent jouer des 5 et avoir un
gros gros pions en gros contrôle du
centre alors quand on veut égaliser au
centre soit on copie les blancs et sur
quatre ont fait eux cinq soit on essaye
de d'échangés d'options 24 contre un
pion des 5 ou un pion de l'ale alors
effectivement il ya plusieurs coups qui
peuvent arriver à ce but soit aussi ce
soit ces six donc le coup c'est si c'est
à coude en masse si on veut amener le
pion de t5 pour que le pion eux quatre
ces échanges alors on regarde des quatre
voilà des cinq voies l'or noir des cinq
donc là et bien effectivement on a
plusieurs possibilités soit on prend
mais dans ces cas là ça serait on peut
bien évidemment il ya une souviennent
variantes
alors on peut mais je dirais presque à
une seule condition c'est que on
enchaîne tout de suite par le coup de la
tête qu'on appelle le tac panov si le
gamme c4 l'expression au centre c'est
une autre variante citoyen dit c'est pas
celle ci donc nous on voit la variante a
pris 10 5 classique
on voit là on peut jouer aussi avant d'
avance mais nous on regarde cavaliers
ses trois marques a blessé trois voilà
qui est une variante ou en garde la
tension au centre c'est à dire que sur
un coup comme des prend 1,4 qui est le
coût normal et bien cavaliers prend 1,4
et alors on a cette position où le
cavalier est bien passé au centre alors
quoi pourquoi des prend 1,4
reste qu'il n'ya pas le possible alors
gardez d'accord maintenant il faut
trouver un coup pour rien s'il n'y a pas
de coup ça
maintenant il faut trouver imaginons un
coup comme cavalier 6 alors que relief
si cela ça serait vraiment de la
provocation puisque on pourrait pousser
eu cinq en gagnant un temps ayant pris
en gentiment le cavalier de reboucher
donc on augmenterait notre domination
centrale tout en gagnant du temps sur le
cavalier f6 ya pas il n'y a pas de coups
alors que faire d'autre
sanaa - coup comme cavalier 17 et bien
le pion des 5es et perdu voilà
et le fou a pas de gaz alors mal fou
voilà en sicile mal placé évident parce
qu'il bloque son pur ef-5 hisser en
prise par le pion ya les paladins de
valada donc malheureusement ce fou fou
fou parce que ça permet aux cadres le
processus la paire le poids des 5es
perdre on joue pas des coudes
développement comme ça donc en fait y'a
pas de conte c'est ça qu'il faut nous
voilà mais regarde bien la forme des
pions des pions noirs ils sont tous sur
les cases blanches
donc en fait l'idée de cette défense
solide c'est de mettre également le pion
aux six sur sur les cases blanches
verrouiller la casse des cinq faire une
sorte de en fait d'eux des taux en fait
de forteresse de points forts de points
forts sera là où c'est un étau des noirs
d'avancé sur le plan des 5 oui on
consolide notre point fort des 5 alors
il y aura un gros inconvénient si on
poussait e6 tout de suite c'est qu'on
enfermerait notre fou ou c8 qui serait
une pièce très faible c'est un gros
pions voilà donc l'idée de la
quarantaine et bien c'est d'obtenir sept
cette formation de pions mais en sortant
d'abord le fou alors comment les séances
ma force presse claude et prendre quatre
voilà des prend 2,4 alors dé prendre
quatre cavaliers prend 4 voilà
maintenant on a deux possibilités la
leçon du jour qui est cavalier 17 et
aussi le couffo f5 faisait alors le
couffo f5
on sort le fou on attaque le cavalier au
cap le cavalier est obligé de reboucher
et en rebouchant angers 3 il va se
venger sur le fouet f50 attaque le
forcing et avec le x 5 on est obligé de
reboucher voilà alors ok ça c'est noté
mais on sait que les noirs ils veulent
sortir le fou mais ils ont pas envie non
plus de perdre du temps avec ce coup de
cavaliers g3 qui va alors forcé à se
bouger le foot bien sûr là qu'est ce
qu'ils ont dans l'arsenal ils ont le
coup cavaillé des 7 vallées 17
alors voilà ça c'est le coup joué par
karpov quasiment toute sa carrière il a
tout aussi un peu fou et 5000 et russes
en tout cas lié 17 ce que l'idée c'est
d'assurer un relais avec le cavalier g8
voilà pour pouvoir échanger ce cavalier
au 4 et ensuite seulement on sortira ce
fou de cases blanches la sortie du foot
cases blanches c'est la manoeuvre clé de
cette variante de la défense karo kann
il faut bien comprendre pourquoi les
noirs jouent comme ça c'est pour sortir
leur [ __ ] case blanche donc à holy 17
5 ou qui est très intéressant alors on
peut essayer de coude à me2 pour faire
un match rapide peut-être alors amis
bien sûr dames 2 ça serait un piège sans
votre ami noté dans me2 sur cavaliers m6
et monologique un qu'on en attend oui ça
serait une grosse faute à cause du
magnifique regardez-moi ça cavale et des
six échecs et mat
voilà général en six coups j'ai déjà
perdu comme ça avec les noirs face est
horrible c'était en bullet sur internet
des partis en une minute je vous
conseille à personne et d'ailleurs une
simple kasparov a perdu presque une
partie comme sa façade hibou
il avait tenté une claro cannes avec les
noirs où c'est un peu différent cette
menace n'était pas aussi n'était pas
aussi sommaire que certains se
présentent avec une dame 2 quand même
qui traînait oui mais c'était un peu
c'était pas un vote rapide c'était pas
mal mais c'était difficulté c'était une
difficulté
elle a permis aux sacrifices y autorise
un sacrifice qui est considéré comme bon
pour les blancs par mathieu voilà donc
validé c'est donc à noter que dans nos
demi finale dames deux il ya simplement
un cavalier des f6 tout simplement un
mollasson dames 2 et cavaliers de tf6
selon karine on peut jouer simplement
car il est ici c'est là il n'y a plus il
ya plus de maths en fait on propose
aussi les chances du cavalier sauf que
on sait pas mater et l'effet d'un
soupçon mieux commencer à 70 plus où il
vaut mieux évidemment d'éviter de se
faire mater alors alors ici on va vous
proposer une variante du dir est simple
à comprendre et qui est en accord et ce
qu'on a dit avant c'est-à-dire qu'on
essaie de lutter contre la sortie du fou
de cases blanches alors rejoint coup
très simple avant tout cesser leurs
attaques
voilà on s'éclate du jusque là c'est pas
c'est pas une surprise le [ __ ] et à
placer ici des noirs jouent leurs courts
et rigides vis aux allergies alors là on
a des grandes lignes des grandes lignes
de cette vente qui a été cette année
partenaire pas au portrait place et
cavaliers g5 cavale et g5 puisque ici on
attaque le pion m 7
délicat voilà je réussis cette fois je
dois dire aussi c'est alors ça séparer
cette menace ce sont des vents théorique
interminable c'est pour ça qu'on propose
des alternatives à cavalli g5 ces cas il
prend un fils tout simplement qu'il ya
quand on accepte l'idée des noirs qui
descend l'escalier menouar question vous
reprenez le cavalier pas question de
doubler des pions comme c'est l'idée
principale de m 15h17 et on joue c3 c3
voilà alors il je te vois venir avec la
grande idée est cosigné n'en a joué le
coup foued 5
voilà maintenant fort et là la belle
manoeuvre les la manoeuvre terrible pour
les world mp3 mp3 puisque ça fait une
double menace à la fois sur le pion à
cet événement ce qui serait un désastre
mais aussi sur le pion bessette qui
serait un désastre avec le pion c6 qui
risquent de tomber aussi un désastre
mais les cases blanches extrêmement
faibles voilà donc ce sont des coups
comme fou et f5 ou comme fou g4 et bien
on adam b3 qui permet qui permet de
gagner un pion est quasiment la partie
sud si on joue comme la braise et que
donc l'idée c'est de lutter contre la
sortie de ce fou et et en plus ces trois
bains ce foot ça consolide le pion le
pion de décade donc c'est pas une
mauvaise affaire
alors ici on a on a plusieurs plusieurs
possibilités alors d'abord on peut
regarder le coup aussi ce qui est un
aveu d'impuissance qui est un petit peu
bizarre stéphane hains puisque là les
noirs font en quelque sorte un aveu
d'impuissance est à dire qui
ils sont désespérés tout de suite parce
qu'ils pourront pas sortir leur fou dont
il cherche à se développer rapidement et
se disent que peut-être avec la firme
cateau b 6 to b 7 on va réussir à sortir
le vous met dans sa structure là on a
quand même une manoeuvre qui est bien
connu qui est de sortir le cavalier en
f3 voilà pour pouvoir occuper la belle
case d'avant postes en 5 avec une petite
pression sur le pion ces six camps les
plus raides poussé en d6 et puis aussi
la pression sur f7 oui l idée du fossé 4
avec la dame wallada aussi le fou
parents bessette et bien s'affaiblir et
encore un peu plus cette diagonale hm2f
donc voilà qu'à liège 3 est un coup très
naturel on peut continuer par exemple
par daems et cette femme c'est cette
voie là donc continue le développement
tout à fait normalement avec petit rock
et hiropon bien là et sur un coup comme
fou et 7
on place de pièces correctement avec une
dame en u2 avec l'idée de sortir plus
tard le fou angers 5 la tour eiffel 20
la torah en d1 voilà un truc très propre
et puis cet avantage des espaces que
nous confère la case d'avant-postes ans
le 5 on va essayer de s'en servir pour
avancer deux pièces un peu plus vers la
position noir et créer des menaces peut
être un peu plus effective sur le petit
rock avec un coup comme fou détroit et
puis pourquoi pas des idées sur achète
[ __ ] bien sûr voilà et une tour qui
peut passer sur la troisième rangée pour
renforcer l'attaqué
donc voilà elles toutes sortes d'idées
possible sur le coup eux six jours voilà
il n'est pas que du coup aussi s'il ya
aussi le coup j'ai 6 ans qu'après ces
trois l'autre coupe au silence alors là
on dit faire alors on va avoir un
logiciel qui va taper évidemment sur wii
ça c'est un peu la confiance à dire que
le fou g7 il tape sur une chaîne de
pions qui est très solide
quand même donc mais l'avantagé c'est
qu'on diffère la sortie de wallace et
construire en garde en réserve quand
même la sortie du four à f/5 ou angers 4
alors son cavalier f3 carl f 3,3 alors
niveau là on peut je fous g4 alors
qu'est ce qui se passait la cfa 2 c'est
que tu es tu à l'affût alors oui
évidemment donc c'est une évidence
le terrible terrible et surprenant au
premier abord fou prend un essai voilà
qui est le coup gagnant puisque après
roy price est tout simplement joues tu
vas rien de saint vallier 1,5 donc vos
recettes c'est horrible puisqu'il ya
échec et ils fourchette sur le fou et la
dame reprendra le cavalier noir on
récupère la pièce en ayant gagné un pion
et en ayant des rockets le roi noir donc
persuadé la notion isolés on sait en
plus donc c'est horrible on peut dire
quand même énorme avantage
voilà gros ça donc on oublie pas qu on
doit toujours surveiller la sortie du
foot cases blanches des noirs et donc
cavalier f3 et bien ne tolère toujours
pas sorti du fou donc adjoint roger
cadeau que c'est un bon coup les noirs
continuent à deux blocs monde pousse
elle est là on va on peut dire 'ok on
waroquet petit rock attention alors
maintenant maintenant la menace rouge et
4 elle existe voilà bien sûr faut pas
que chacun peut prendre de la tour voilà
le problème c'est qu'on peut quand même
un moment donné on ne peut plus
tellement l'empêcher
est-ce que les vraiment si embêtante que
ça c'est pas sûr parce que on a quand
même une formation ancien ghetto elle a
par exemple tout roule donc un coût
normal parce qu'on a vraiment un pion
aux tournées on l'espère physique la
tresse africaine parce que sur fuji kaï
par exemple sur flu gk et bien moi jouer
à trois là ça oblige l échange de fou
sinon je le vois je viens de repartir
ses inconvénients du funk et ozil à g4
après ça gagnerait le fou faut prendre
le cavalier dans la paire de faux on
donne la perte de fou donc c'est pas
forcément une très bonne affaire petit
avantage blanc cause de la paire de fois
le transplant durable petit mais
vraiment durable ça va ça va durer assez
longtemps de chances de gain voilà une
bonne pression de la perte de fou sur le
centre et puis madame des plans assez
facile du parlant de doublement de
détour se connaître peut donc en
filigrane ne reste pas en reste pas un
bon coup c'est toujours pas bon donc on
va continuer à se développer avec les
noirs dit mais de façon tout en
différant la sortie du fou donc que dams
et cette voix là et on voit que le prof
du fou est pas tout à fait résolus ce
qu'on rêve c'est qu'en plus on voit bien
à cause du firm piétons on a du mal à
sortir se fout toujours parce qu'on lève
5 qui déjeunaient pourra jamais retourné
en justice
là il peut pas faire machine arrière et
puis et puis on voit pas trop ce qu'il
fait en f 5 aussi ça
oui les attaques que rien ici on joue au
cices il va quand même se retrouver
coincé devant ses pions à lier un coin
n'a pas sur le gâteau c'est pas grave de
m g 6e même s'ils n'y fait rien même si
l'état peut rien parce que bon il est
quand même actif sur le problème c'est
que effectivement si on les enferme
après il a un peu mauvaise posture donc
cesser la construction que tous et c'est
pas facile pour une classe pour ce fou
voilà donc la lors d'un second tour et
bien sûr la menace et les directs double
les pièces cours sur la colonie pour lui
tant 8 on veut pas quand même enfermé
notre fou de classe blanche toujours on
en garde le pion en deux sets et la
foulée 5 voilà bon voilà on peut
considérer qu on a une partie quand même
très agréable avec cavaliers e5 ensuite
comme d'habitude les tests d'avant poste
va tôt ou tard je regarde les cinq
cadavres poche empêcher ce pion de toute
façon de se libérer à tout jamais voilà
avec une pression sur f7 aussi qui est
quand même très agréable
il peut y avoir envoyé quand on mettra
le cavalier a eu 5 si les noirs sont
forcés de jouer aussi ça m'a fait bien
les cases noires donc c'est voilà on va
tomber d'un avantage professionnel en un
autre avantage positionnelle donc c'est
pas si évident à jouer pour les noirs
c'est facile pour les blancs cca c'est
ça coule un peu facilement - les cases
sont faciles à trouver pour la pour les
pour les pièces blanches donc c'est pas
une ouverture vraiment difficile à jouer
et sur ces trois points on a quand même
le coût principal le coût principal est
là qu'il faut où il faut connaître
on va se retrouver ça c'est cette voie
là c'est celle qui tourne gaz naturel
dans là car aucun intérêt car au
classement ces dates sur l ol a
quasiment tout envie de le voir
d'ailleurs mais dans les grandes
variantes aussi on a retrouvé dams et
c'est tout à fait donc ici sur dame deux
dames 2 voilà pourquoi pas donc on
protège
la case cinq ou six on envisager
peut-être même de faire en europe
pourquoi pas peut-être et on prépare
aussi cavalier f3 sur un coût fixe bien
sûr puisque là on va pouvoir toujours
menacés faut prendre cette voie là sur
un coup x 4 sur 10 ont assis je sais pas
on imagine on a six dames menaces en
tout cas des blancs ces cavaliers f3000
et froid pour venir sur l'avant poste 5
et surtout j'ai capté sur free g4 et
bien aujourd hui fu prend elle s'est
encore une fois on ça peut marcher
puisque sur roy prend qu'à l'aller où
cheikh en général si la dame était en d1
on pourrait faire dame en cavale voilà
c'est pour c'est l'idéal c'est cette
c'est pour ça il fallait montrer la
variante mais la dame en e2 sur le thème
prendre 5 évidemment on reprend avec la
dame on reprend avec la dame dans ce cas
là et c'est pas bon pour les pour les
noirs on peut pas reprendre avec le fou
est donc calais seine va gagner le fou
g4 avec toujours le même problème donc
cabriès 3 est une est une vraie menace
ici sur après d'un peu d'eau voilà donc
fou j'ai quatre fous g4 en fait on
anticipe donc un rêve trop on prendra
tout de suite oui voilà est sûr qu'avec
trois jeux aussi ça c'est aussi voilà
mai
les noirs battant sont en mesure de
bouger cadre le clip dames c'est ça
aussi c'est de protéger le pion b71 on
ne l'a pas dit mais la pub et c'est donc
à éliminer les monades après le fou
était prêt à sortir
assumez-vous g4 alors ils sont un peu
dans le dans le désert comme ça donc on
peut s'en prendre fou maintenant ayant
besoin f3 on peut jouer à trois alors
avec le petit désavantage pour les
blancs et donc on a pris les deux cases
de sortie du cabinet exact mais on a une
idée précise alors un coup r5 il faut f5
et le seul coup un peu raisonnable
ouanna g4 on prend l'espace le fou vient
angers 6 g plâtre ont fini expansion
carrément les lois donc on va parler que
de ce côté on verra on verra mais enfin
a priori non on paiera on évite alors
fou g6 way f4 et là le guide est donc
ces aides 4 avec la menace simple f5 et
le fouet prix voilà une menace très
simple et puis aussi le coup et 4 qui
nous permet de résoudre le problème
tu parlais avec lecavalier n'est pas de
case lecavalier jean mathon retrouve sa
case en f3 ils reçoivent qu'elle sera
soutenue par le piaf case qui est le
plus mal et on appris de l'espace avec
lequel j'ai quatre ris parce qu'on aura
une très très bonne case en poste encore
plus solide donc la fougue 4 c'est le
coup classique quand on a ri se faire
enfermer évidemment reviennent qu'à leur
salaire très bon puisque ça attaque la
tourache un milliardaire russe oleg rien
sur le coup en allant il faut jouer
qu'avec trois n'a pas le choix mais
c'est bien puisque l'option gkd n'est
pas vraiment en prise parce que le fou
j'ai carrément prise et si les noirs
font d'abord font prendre cavaliers pour
se dire après je prendrai options g4 ça
marche pas puisqu'après d'enfants et en
3d l'hôtel j'en tiens un soutien c'est
tranquille donc votre iphone 3 un fou
des 5
et ça c'est malin oui on essaye de
changer parce que c'est on va changer le
monde est fou voilà un contre eux quand
même un fou qui était qu'est super vin
se voilant 4-1 alors on peut prendre en
fou prend baisser un peu prendre il n'y
a pas de ya pas de problème parce que
sur eux prend des cinq qui se
stabiliserait un petit peu la structure
de pions bien on a
des possibilités qui sont intéressantes
par exemple cavaliers au 5ème menace
dame bessin évidemment dam des cinq
échecs aux grands il y aura deux y'a pas
de défense qu convenable voilà donc on
va reprendre du cavalier en d5 donc
parce que l'idée si les musulmans jouent
à 6 par exemple des symptômes contre en
asie en cavale il prend bois qu'elle
prend des cinq cavaliers de siècle car
il ya hossein
voilà donc là on est sur l'avant-poste
maintenant il faut penser aux fous
évidemment il faudrait forcer à se
développer donc aussi surnaturelle et
batna comme peaches et on va quand même
préféré le grand roque
c'est quand même plus cinq verres petit
rock mais sur des gens fous des deux qui
incombe on se serait bien passé parce
que quand on dit tout à l'heure en
sortir un fou oui d'une case ça fait pas
toujours plaisir mais il a peut-être des
perspectives intéressant de ce fou mais
tout s'est toujours bien dans la carro
cannes centimes fondé deux parce qu'en
fait ils dominent le cavaly centrale
voilà des obsèques à peut-être trouvé
une case intéressant dans ces trois
après la poussée c3 c4 aussi une case
intéressante oui c'est à dire qu'on va
on va déloger le cavalier des cinq par
le coup c3 c4 tôt ou tard une fois qu'il
aura bougé
le fou va trouver une case naturel en c3
voilà alors grand roque voilà grand
roque c5 c5 de la plainte de la part des
typiques de la carro cannes on essaye de
faire assez tôt on essaye d'affaiblir le
centre des blancs tu en prends ces cinq
est logique aussi mois la forêt parce
que c'est prendre si l'on s'en va
s'offrir un pion isolé faut prendre ces
cinq gros bien trop bien toujours utile
un puisque pour éviter les échecs sur
les nez sur les cases noires et après
tour hf 8 très important pour contrôler
la caserne sous la prison
du cavaliere 5 eh bien là c'est le
regret regardé les deux derniers coups
des blancs pour avoir une idée de la
variance s'est cassé quatre cavaliers f6
c3 et ça c'est un développement
classement la roma on a une position
harmonieuse tout et consolider les
pièces sont placés sur les cases
optimale et avec nos trois pions fgh
contre les quatre qui sont fixés eh bien
on va essayer de pousser nos trois pions
pour affaiblir la structure des noirs
certains appellent une attaque dominant
c'est exactement était de minorité qu'on
a l'habitude de voir dans d'autres
variantes sur l'autre à elle d'ailleurs
mais sinotruk de minorités avec trois
pions on les pousse on les envoie sur
les 4 pourquoi s'affaiblissent donc
c'est s'assurer que ces trois pions vont
faire pression sur ils sont plus
nombreux à en fixer les trois pions en
verre vont faire pression sur les quatre
pions en voyage pour un affaiblissement
et les pièces blanches pour essayer de
tirer profit des élèves l'histoire que
de ce côté évidemment il ya un petit
avantage numérique puisqu'il ya trois
contrevenants emmanuel majorité et puis
les noirs ne peuvent pas faire la même
chose puisque c'est le roi qui est
derrière travail ne peut pas pousser les
pions comme ça bien sûr
petit avantage blanc durable pour
arriver à harmonieux quand tu disais
sont alors effectivement harmonieuse
sont relativement faciles à jouer
voilà donc c'est contre la carro cannes
de que karpov caille 17
et bien vous conseille pas vraiment
d'entrer dans les grandes lignes
parce que finalement la théorie il assez
convaincante pour les noirs une pression
qui est très solide jouer cette petite
ligne qui est saine pas trop dur à
retenir et avec des petits pièges en
plus c'est ça qui est bien c'est qu'il
ya une ouverture scène où il ya des
petits pièges
c'est toujours agréable parce qu'on peut
gagner la partie très vite celle sur un
an
on a vu toutes les pièces avaient forgé
quatre autos madrid il faut prendre
l'elysée l'idée est simple et puis il ya
des petites idées pour pour gagner la
partie
très vite alors c'était notre leçon
aujourd'hui sur la carreau cannes
variante cavalli 17
merci jean baptiste un merci stéphane à
bientôt